for this palestinian family two upcoming
elections are producing
two very different reactions ablahamdan
like her husband jamal is palestinian
but unlike him she's also a citizen of
israel
she can take part in the country's polls
on tuesday
and while she doesn't expect real change
she says voting is a duty
if i give up this right then i have
given the others the chance to decide on
my future
the political decision follows the
majority and if i didn't vote
how can i complain later jamal is
allowed to live with his family in
israel
but he's not an israeli citizen he can
only cast ballots in palestinian polls
in the occupied west bank and gaza
and he'll get that chance in may the
long
overdue parliamentary elections are the
first
in 15 years however
jamal won't be voting
my vote doesn't make a difference the
same people will stay in power
regardless
the faces of palestinian officials may
change but their policies are the same
israel has the upper hand here when it
comes to the occupied territory
according to pollsters jamal's opinion
is not popular among most palestinians
we got the impression by the data
that palestinians are looking positively
at the fact that israel is having
election
and that the palestinian public at large
miss election when it comes to elections
in israel
palestinians worry that no matter who
wins
the country's leaders will continue to
control the lands and lives of
palestinians
israeli settlers living in the heart of
the west bank
can put up election campaign posters and
have a say in their future
but palestinians living in the same area
cannot put up posters like
these and their leaders in the
palestinian authority
can change so little in the reality
under occupation
back at the hamdan household habla says
the determination of palestinian
israelis to have their say
is the only way to make a difference
as a citizen i know that israel is
working for its own benefit
it's far-fetched to assume that israel
cares about
us as a palestinian minority so let's
start showing that we are present
change doesn't happen in a day jamal has
never voted in his life
and habla will cast her fourth ballot in
two years
they may disagree politically but both
share the hope for a better future for
their children
the occupied west bank okay i want to
focus now on the israeli election though
happening on tuesday and the main
political
forces you've got benjamin netanyahu's
liquid party it has the largest share of
seats in the israeli parliament but it
faces a greater threat from other
right-wingers
instead of the usual center and left
leading the opposition
you've got the former journalist yay
lapid and the centrist yesh ateed party
promising good governance obviously
trying to capitalize on netanyahu's
corruption trials
the right-wing yamina party headed by
former education and defense minister
naftali bennett has criticized the prime
minister's handling of the pandemic
uh there's new hope made up of formerly
good politicians
making its electoral debut in fact the
party leader guinea
tsar has further has positioned himself
further to the right
of prime minister netanyahu and then
there's benigns netanyahu's main
challenger in three previous
elections but now facing pretty much
political wipeout
supporters have abandoned his blue and
white party since he joined the
netanyahu-led coalition
last year with us from west jerusalem
mitchell
barrack a pollster at kivon global
research also the former spokesperson
for the israeli president
shimon peres nice to see you mention we
i lost track of the number of times i've
spoken to you in the last two years
about
israeli elections they seem to happen so
often
as i read through that list of parties
there the first thing that strikes me is
that there isn't an opposition
well there isn't a strong opposition
there's just lots of little fractured
parts of it and that was
well that can't be good for the
electoral process or at least trying to
find
a a majority somewhere
well i think that's going to help
netanyahu it's interesting because you
know we're now in our fourth election
up until now the first three were really
it i wouldn't call it an even match but
it was
netanyahu versus guns so there were
people that voted netanyahu there are
people that voted guns and some voted
for the smaller parties
now there isn't one you know solid
opposition against the prime minister
there's a group of
really three or four parties or even
five parties or six
parties that have committed to being
against netanyahu
and those parties may get together
and you know form a government that
really ends netanyahu's career
the problem is for the public they don't
see any one person as being the leader
of that
so it's going to be hard to really see
who's going to
step forward whether it's you know the
person as you mentioned yay lapid
who will probably have the most votes uh
after netanyahu
whether it's gidon tsar who comes from
the right from the likud
or naftali bennett who comes from the
right of the likud
it is still not clear and i don't think
we're going to know
okay and so prime minister netanyahu the
great survivor
a man with all these corruption
allegations against him
is actually the strongest player here
well he is and he isn't i mean it's it's
basically been for the past you know
uh almost 10 years netanyahu runs
against himself
meaning basically he's running against
himself the thing is like this there is
a lot of fatigue
for finishing up with netanyahu people
are used to the corruption although some
people say okay
you know he's under trial but most
people it's not a burning issue
but people are already you know he's
been like a total of 14 or 15 years here
as prime minister
so people are getting fatigued of that
can i interrupt you mitchell sorry
how is it not a burning issue how is it
not a burning issue that the leader of
the country
is under the microscope like this surely
that is something which would make
people
think again we're used to it we're used
to it already each election
we got a little bit more desensitized
first it's the you know what's going to
happen when the police recommend an
indictment
what's going to happen when he actually
the attorney general recommends an
indictment
what happens when he actually gets
indicted and what happens when he's on
trial
so we've passed all that but here's the
thing and why he's not running as he
should be
in the time that he formed the last
government till now of which he really
broke the deal with benny gonz
okay he's made two peace treaties like
out of nowhere
with bahrain and the united arab
emirates you know warmed relations with
morocco we have more peace treaties
probably coming
and israel has vaccinated more than half
of its population five million people
even though he mishandled even though he
mishandled a lot of the closures and the
other things
he should really be polling not at 30
seats but at 42 seats at 43 seats
meaning these are tremendous
achievements and he's not seeing that
he's not seeing that enthusiasm that
blind support at the polls
because people are tired of going to the
polls and he's wearing thin on some
people
but that doesn't mean that he won't have
the advantage and as with most elections
it's all going to boil down to turnout
and the one thing i can predict
is that we are not we're probably not
going to know the results
not even the night of the election but
not for another week or two weeks
until president ruby rivlin decides who
can form the government
and then to have an actual government
form this is going to be a long process
because the other thing to keep in mind
is
all of these parties have painted
themselves in a corner
because they've all said who they're not
going to sit with i'm not going to sit
with this one i'm not going to go here
i'm not going to go there
with all of those requirements it's
going to be very very difficult
to form a government for anyone for any
candidate
deja vu all over again isn't it mr
barrett great to talk to you
thank you thank you